[Applause]  McCullum 4:3 a great first quarter and  then hung on here's Lillard with the  shot clock cream look at this Lillard  pulls up the clocks going on he had to  force that up in him up needle and run  the break Camino gives it to Lillard  three-pointer is  chance it for for the brizzy's up and  just drop that thing in with the foul  great shot by Lillard it is down to  three Portland a chance to tie or get  within one  here's McCollum  [Applause]  that  Charles and Shaq they got the American  Express halftime report  to talk about with this him Westbrook  from behind the arc is now our four he  is 3 for 15 shooting in this game  30-footers in this series already  five point Portland lead with a ball  McCullen Katrine  [Applause]  unball by Dame coming up with felt  inaudible applause so a step-back three  pointer is up  [Applause]  the third  six threes of the quarter